لكن ما هي الذخائر دقيقه التوجيه التي
ستزيد روسيا من انتاجها تعرف بانها سلاح
يدمر هدفا ما بدقه مع تقليل الاضرار
الجانبيه الناجمه عن هذا التدمير وتشمل
هذه الذخائر الصواريخ الباليستيه وقذائف
المدفعيه وغيرها هذه الذخائر مزوده بنظام
تحديد المواقع العالمي جي بي اس او
التوجيه بالليزر او انظمه الملاحه بالقصور
الذاتي لتحسين دقه السلاح وتقليلها مش
الخطا الى اقل من ثلاثه امتار توجه
الذخائر نحو اهداف ثابته او متحركه محدوده
او كبيره وسواء كانت على الارض او البحر
او في الجو وهي تستخدم كسلاح مضاد
للطائرات والسفن وغيرها على سبيل المثال
تستخدم روسيا صواخير صواريخ كينجال في حرب
اوكرانيا تتميز بان انحرافها عن الهدف لا
يتجاوز مترا واحدا اما صواريخ اسكندر ام
وصواريخ تيركون